HBO's sci-fi series Westworld takes us
on an intriguing journey into an
artificially intelligent future and a
synthetic reimagined past to a place
where incredibly lifelike robots cater
to the every whim of human guests as an
Old West theme park based on Michael
Crichton's 1973 movie of the same name
the show brings together a fantastic
cast including Anthony Hopkins Jeffrey
Wright and Evan Rachel Wood so let's
take a look at ten crazy facts about
HBO's Westworld
the fly that crawls across the face of
Dolores Abernathy in the show's premier
is actually real in fact the production
lists three fly Wranglers in its credits
and according to actress Evan Rachel
Wood who plays West world's oldest host
the flies used in the scene with
semi-frozen so they were in a dormant
state then when they were placed on her
face they stored and crawled around for
10 minutes until eventually they could
fly away however of course when we see
the fly on her eyeball that isn't real
but was added later in post-production
apparently Evan Rachel Wood got so Zen
during filming that she actually fell
asleep while she was shooting a scene
with Jeffrey Wright who plays the head
of West world's programming division
Bernard lo it happened during one of the
show's analysis mode scenes which are
when the park staff questioned the hosts
who aren't meant to remember anything
about it
Wood says that filming those scenes was
almost like meditating or going into a
hypnotic state and she had to really
concentrate on every move she made
because each slight move or subtle
facial expression would really affect
how Dolores would be interpreted by both
the other characters in the story and by
the audience watching the show at home
although it's a rather adult theme park
compared to Disneyland Westworld was
actually inspired by the happiest place
on earth yes when author michael
crichton first saw Disneyland's
animatronics it gave him the idea to
write and direct the 1970s movie
Westworld
which this new series draws on likewise
showrunners Jonathan Nolan and Lisa joy
have designed their Westworld theme park
to be as they see it a fantasy world
compelling enough to last generations in
other words it's a cultural institution
much like Disneyland indeed one of the
inspirations behind the show's character
dr. Robert Ford who founded West Wales
Park is Walt Disney himself and not
Jurassic Park founder John
as show anna-lysa joy says she's never
seen the dinosaur-sized blockbuster
which is funny because the character of
John Hammond was also created by author
Michael Crichton I was likened to Walt
Disney
the production crew transported several
big interior sets from California to
Castle Valley and Deadhorse Point State
Park in Utah where they filmed a number
of the show's exteriors
for example during filming they put the
set for the Train we see arriving at
West's world on a large flatbed truck
and drove it up and down routes 128 in
Utah so where we see the show's
characters looking out of the train
window they're actually looking out at
the real Utah landscape and not a green
screen
Sharon is Jonathan Nolan and Lisa joy
shows Utah for filming West's world as
they wanted the show in its theme park
to have the feel of a vast landscape
scene and director John Ford's classic
Westerns which also shot in the state
however the town at the heart of West
world was filmed melody ranch in
California Santa Clarita Valley which
has been home to many productions from
the 1950s Lone Ranger TV series to
Deadwood and the recent Magnificent
Seven remake
according to the website deadline Xers
who appeared in West world were asked to
sign a pretty interesting consent form
the form included possible requirements
the extras might face on set for example
to have their genitals painted or to
pose on all fours while others who are
fully nude right on their back or even
to contort to form a table like shape or
being fully nude the Hollywood web site
also said the extras were paid around
$600 for the shoot which is nearly four
times their usual day rate HBO responded
to the claim saying that the document
was created by an outside extras casting
vendor and that it was not requested
written or approved by HBO Warner
Brothers television or the producers
Sharon is Jonathan Nolan and Lisa joy
did a lot of research to create the
theme park in West world
this included visiting Las Vegas to
study how casinos are laid out and
specifically how the strip is designed
to lure visitors into different
experiences Nolan and joy also dug deep
into the contemporary world of augmented
reality and explored the rules under
which artificial intelligence is created
and destroyed in fact some of the
questions put to West Wales host for
example whether they're lying or based
on criteria used by real-life AI
researchers to decide if the AI they're
creating is problematic
the station's Nolan and joy had with
people in Silicon Valley about the
current and future state of AI were
mostly off-the-record
so they also decided to bring that
notion of extreme secrecy to their show
video games such as Red Dead Redemption
Skyrim Grand Theft Auto and a number of
games by Bioware also had a big impact
on West world while Jonathan Nolan is a
longtime gamer his fellow showrunner
Lisa joy isn't so to fully understand
the rules and components of gameplay
which were crucial for their show they
played a lot of Grand Theft Auto
together
however Joy's approach to the game was
rather unusual and included obeying
traffic signs rather than mowing people
down when it came to writing the show
the realism immersion violence idea of
morality is a variable and the level of
sophistication of non player characters
and contemporary gaming all made their
mark on West Wales theme park movie wise
Ridley Scott's Blade Runner was also an
influence on West world in fact Jonathan
Nolan says he's watched the 1982 classic
sci-fi flick countless times as it's his
brother Christopher's favorite film and
while the look of West world's amusement
park draws on the classic westerns of
director John Ford for the control-room
seems to show cinematographer Paul
Cameron went for a mix of the starkness
of 2001 a Space Odyssey and a Clockwork
Orange for the upper floors and
slaughterhouse-five for the bottom floor
Nolan has also compared the amnezia
programmed into West world's hosts to
the uneasier of guy Pearce's character
in the movie memento which was based on
Jonathan's short story and adapted for
the big screen by his brother
Christopher
you can thank JJ Abrams co-creator of
lost and director of Star Wars The Force
awakens for getting the ball rolling on
the new West world series Abrams came up
with the idea to turn Michael Crichton's
original movie on its head and focus a
new series on the robot characters in
their perspective rather than just the
parks human guests funnily enough this
isn't the first time the Abrams has
tried to get a new worse world off the
ground over 20 years ago he sat down
with Michael Christ and although things
didn't work out to bring the new West
world to live Abrams who was also
produced on person of interest reached
out to that show's creator Jonathan
Nolan who's co-written movies such as
interstellar and the Dark Knight with
his brother Christopher and West world
is the first collaboration between Nolan
and his wife Burn Notice producer Lee
the perforated paper rolls that spin
through the saloons play a piano
performing old-timey versions of songs
by the likes of Radiohead and the
Rolling Stones a real fully functioning
roles created especially for the show by
Steven Kent Goodman whose
california-based company Norville tea
rolls was given a super tight deadline
to complete the highly specialized work
Jonathan Nolan has said that the player
piano that features in dr. Robert Ford's
workshop the saloon and the title
sequence is a shout out to author Kurt
Vonnegut whose first novel player piano
was published in 1952 and takes place in
an almost fully mechanized near future
and not only does the instrument serve
as a metaphor for West world's hosts but
the fact that it plays modern music in
an old fashion style is also a reminder
of just how artificial and anachronistic
the show's theme park is now guys what
do you think of West well so far and
what are your theories about the world
this show set in let me know in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
do comment like and hit that subscribe
button and before you head off I've got
some really interesting videos exploring
the making of movies like ex machina and
interstellar so click here to check
those out thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers